keeping it moving 600 entertainment meet
the Sixers is on the way meet the Sixers
on the way man meet the Sixers now y'all
heard young hood and I'm pretty sure
y'all remember Ros Sama Rama but godd
damn it we back and we better let's go
let's
[Music]
go
yeah I said
my partner got me a pended I ain't been
acting the same nichlas pieace get your
ass roped up for this chain know some
[__] that a crash if you merge in my
Lane the weather man or Lamar can even
stop all this rain purified gold pieces
steady hugging my teeth invisible s
diamonds John Cena couldn't see walking
Wendy's with the uzi that's the only
real beef I got CH off the block like
government cheese gold medals on my neck
look like I came in first place in the
knth with the Stars sound like I live
out of space [__] gaming for this
bread I told them bake me a cake and
then I pop up at your house like State
form and I'm Jake I'm celing ain't no
way the [__] [__] with me bounce
house in a row look how I jumped in the
streets What's Beef when I deliver this
[__] like uber e store a sign like you
ain't even never heard about the g off
the flap I was trying to get green like
we dispense a superstar Pride mama don't
worry I'm painting PCT neckl came in my
ear for me to listen walk around with so
much can you thought a [__] was temping
take the skull you see my [__] is up
all this smoke in the earth it look like
we blowing blunts in your sex and
kicking [__] all my [__] practice
punts no runs just a Double Cup baby
bottle fruit punch oh it's up and you
know it I'm trying to take this [__]
over coas to watch bus and flood it with
water like Nova scoa bre like some Earth
fry wings or a toaster motion like a
quarterback signal you you scoot over uh
daily wages will have a niggaer in PAC
and empty out any house and leave that
[__] BAC and tragic dismember
bodies and olders will leave them
stanking dreams the money to comeing
with unfamiliar faces
Lord bro my
God hey it's safe to say uh y' y'all
might be the [__] best rapping Squad
in the whole game right now I don't know
who out rapping all three of y'all I
don't know man 600 entertainment man
damn made the six is on the way man fire
that [__] was hard that [__] was hard
bro that [__] was [__] hard hey you
just watched another freestyle brought
to you by the good Folks at LRG goddamn
it shout out to LRG all right go use the
promo code bootleg right now on their
website l-r-g.com save 40% off at
checkout 40% off at checkout use that
promo code and we got another freestyle
coming ASAP oh